All right, professor, what are you, what are you,
what are we talking about today?
I was going to talk about a paper entitled Gaya,
early data released three acceleration of the solar system from Gaia, Austria.
Professor. You are loving all these findings that are coming out of Gaia, right?
It's a brilliant mission. And, and actually, you know,
I think the best is yet to come because it's the nature of this telescope.
Its sole ambition is to measure the positions of about a billion
stars and various other objects in space and to continue to monitor them.
And the primary science goal is to measure this phenomenon called parallax,
which is basically as the satellite, as it's orbiting the earth,
the earth goes around the sun,
which means it's sort of viewing the nearby universe from different places and
in doing so it's viewing things from slightly different directions.
You end up seeing the stars,
move a little bit and the classic way of illustrating this is this the same
phenomenon.
If you hold your finger up in front of your nose and then close one eye and
close the other eye and your finger jumps,
just because your eyes are viewing it from slightly different directions and the
further your finger is away from your face, the less your finger jumps.
When you make that, do that in the library.
Professor, this might say something about me, but I remember like, you know,
when Hubble went up and talk about James Webb and there's so much hype and
excitement, I feel like I don't even remember guy going up.
I don't remember people talking about it.
It just kind of one day you started telling me, look at all this amazing data.
And I'm like, where does this come from?
[Inaudible].
I guess it's partly because it's a little bit more specialized and astrometry,
you know, it's a, it's a classic subject.
And for the longest time it may very little progress.
But then we first had this mission called the park costs in the 1990s.
And then Gaia is kind of the successes of that,
which have kind of completely revolutionized what these telescopes could do.
The accuracy of the missions.
What's this paper telling us.
So we need to back up a little bit first. Um, am I need to talk about, uh, uh,
a bit of astronomy called stellar aberration. It sort of came with the birth of,
of, uh, people trying to measure parallax. So back in the 18th century,
there was a guy called Bradley. James Bradley was his name.
There was trying to measure the distances to stars from this parallax effect.
And what he actually found is that the stars do indeed move over the course of a
year, but in completely the wrong pattern for it to be the parallax effect.
And by far too large and amount.
And what he did uncovered was this phenomenon called stellar aberration.
And he was actually also the person, not only who discovered it,
but also came up with the explanations to what's going on.
Why stars wobble around over the course of the year. And in essence,
it comes down to, if you think about going out in the rain,
like if there were an, imagine the rains falling straight down on your head,
if you're standing still,
the rain falls on your head and you can tell the rain is coming from right up.
But if you start walking then because there's now a relative motion between you
and the rain, the rain actually starts hitting you in the face, right?
If you're carrying an umbrella, you have to tilt your umbrella forward.
You get exactly the same thing with stars, right?
That actually the direction in which the Starlight is coming depends on the
direction in which you're moving. If you're not moving, then you know,
maybe the Starlight will be coming from directly ahead.
But if the us moving then the net effect of that is that the Starlight appears
to come from a slightly different direction just because you had the relative
speeds together and you end up shifting the direction the is coming from.
And of course over the course of a year, as the earth goes around the sun,
its motion is in different directions at different times,
which means this effect shifts stars in different directions at different times
of the year.
So this guy Bradley figured all this out and actually used it to make the first
reasonably accurate measurement of the speed of light,
because it's all to do with the amount that this affects the size of this
effect, just depends on the relative speed of the earth,
which they knew compared to the speed of light.
Now that story is not quite true because it turns out,
of course you can't do it. So this involved adding speeds, right? That I said,
well, the speed of the things traveling at some speed.
And then there's the relative motion of the earth. We added speeds together.
One of those speeds we added together in this particular case was the speed of
light. And you're not supposed to do that because you aren't into all sorts of
relativistic effects. That says actually,
when you get close to the speed of light, you can't just add speeds together.
So that the real story is a little more complicated. And in fact,
stellar aberration was what led to the formation,
the formulation of special relativity, but at least in qualitative terms,
this idea of thinking about it in terms of rain falling on your head still works
pretty well. If we move forward to the 19th century, um,
there was an astronomer called John pond who was also interested in paradox and
he pointed out an interesting thing, which is that,
that was just thinking about the earth moving around the sun. But of course,
if the sun's moving relative to the stars,
then that should produce the same effect.
What he pointed out is that if the sun were to accelerate or decelerate,
so if it speed were to change,
then actually that change in speed would lead to a change in this effect just as
if you speed sped up or slowed down, walking in the rain.
And therefore you ought to see things move due to the acceleration or
deceleration of the sun. A little bit later in the 19th century,
John Herschel came along and said, that's all very well.
And it's a very neat idea,
but of course we now know as they did by then that the stars are all moving as
well. They will have their own proper motions. So he said, you know,
trying to separate out the motion that due to the acceleration of the
sun from just the fact that the stars are all moving around anyway,
and we can now measure those is hopeless, right?
You're never actually going to be able to do that.
And the reason why suddenly it comes back to life again is Gaia is measuring the
positions of billions of stars,
but it's also measuring some other things as well. And in particular,
there are about a million quasars that it's measuring. So these,
these very distant galaxies were incredibly bright star like output because have
central engines, they're central black holes are incredibly bright.
So to all intents and purposes, they look just like stars.
And so Gaia can measure them. But of course they don't move well.
They probably do move,
but there are such huge distances away that effectively they form an unmoving
reference frame.
That means that if pond's original idea was right and the sun
were accelerating,
then we should be able to detect it by looking for the aberration.
It induces in all these distant quasars,
they'll all start to have a proper motion just due to the fact that the sun is
accelerating over time.
And so even though the signal in any one particular quasar is absolutely tiny
because we've got a million of them and we know what patterns to look for.
We can kind of average all that information together to try and measure the
acceleration of the sun. And that's what this paper did.
All right.
This brings me to the question that's been burning a hole in my head for the
last five to 10 minutes. Why is the Sonic celebrating at all?
The main reason the is accelerating is because he's orbiting around the Milky
way. And of course, to get something to go round in a circle,
you have to accelerate it.
There's this phenomenon called centripetal acceleration the movement there
because it's not traveling in a straight line. It's velocity is changing.
That means you're accelerating it.
So we get actually have a reasonable prediction as to what we expect the
acceleration of the sun to be.
And also what direction we expected to be in because centripetal acceleration,
it's seeking the center, centripetal acceleration.
So it's actually all should be accelerating towards the center of the galaxy.
So that's the phenomenon. These guys measured. Let me just read the results,
our best estimates of the acceleration based on dire EDR threes.
That's the data they look at is 2.3,
two plus or minus 0.16 times 10 to the minus 10 meters per second
squared.
So it's an acceleration of two times 10 to the minus 10 meters per second
squared. So that's 0.9 zeros,
two meters per second squared. That's a really small, that's absolutely tiny.
It means over the course of a year,
the speed of the sun changes by less than a centimeter
per second.
Where's the energy coming from to do that from gravity. Yeah.
It's just the pull of gravity stuff.
So the pull of gravity is what's pulling it round, accelerating it round.
It's just Newton's second law force equals mass times acceleration where the
force is the gravitational pull of the galaxy towards the center.
And the acceleration is the centripetal acceleration towards the center. Now,
the reason why it's tiny is you're, you're quite right.
The actual acceleration on kind of astronomical timescales is quite large,
but that's the thing.
You have to accelerate it around in a circle over the course of 200 million
years, right? At the time it takes to go round. So that means the amount of the,
the, the speed needs to change. Each second is absolutely tiny.
So we think the sun's going around the Milky way at something like 230
kilometers per second, we think we know the distance of the center.
So actually we can predict what that acceleration more or less ought to be.
It's probably a bit more complicated because there'll be local effects,
you know, that causing the sun to accelerate,
there are nothing to do with that global acceleration,
but actually it turns out that the number they get here is almost exactly the
same as that figure you would expect. And then of course,
the last bit is I mentioned that not only do you get the size of the
acceleration, you get the direction of the acceleration as well,
and the direction is pointed right at the center of the galaxy.
So this is exactly,
exactly what you'd expect for that kind of centripetal acceleration effect.
So they've used all these stars and this guy data to calculate something that
could have calculated pretty easily at another way.
You know, at some level it's a trivial calculation,
cause we sort of already knew what the answer is. It's sort of reassuring.
It gave the right answer.
Technically it's absolutely amazing that they can measure an acceleration
directly measured, you know, pre the previous, you know,
we think the acceleration has to be, this was all indirectly inferred, right?
They've measured it, they've measured this acceleration, this tiny.
Want it to point and keep it there.
And it's actually surprisingly simple physics and it's all down to the
conservation of angular momentum. Now you might see in,
in some science fiction shows like Battlestar Galactica or something like that,
uh, that they maneuver spacecraft with thrusters.